Salut, aujourd'hui c'est le jour de l'explication de la semaine.
L'autre jour vous m'avez avoué vous regardez souvent cette vidéo
dans votre lit le dimanche matin à 11h quand elle sort.
Elle sort tous les dimanches à 11h celle-ci.
Alors je me suis dit bah comme c'est dimanche :
Je fais la vidéo depuis mon canapé !
Ça me donne l'illusion moi aussi d'être un dimanche où je fais pas grand chose.
Je crois qu'on a trouvé le rythme de croisière sur la chaîne, vous avez remarqué ça.
Le lundi, je mentalise quelqu'un en vidéo.
Le mardi également.
Le mercredi, je donne toujours une astuce pour devenir un peu plus mentaliste.
Le jeudi, maintenant c'est le nouveau rendez-vous
je parle d'un petit peu ce que je veux.
Le vendredi, je mentalise encore quelqu'un que j'ai rencontré dans ma semaine
Euh le samedi, c'est le Masterclass, la vidéo un petit peu plus longue.
Et le dimanche ce sont les explications.
Je vous explique toujours quelque chose
qui va vous permettre de bluffer quelqu'un directement au repas que vous allez faire peut-être dans la journée
ou dans votre semaine.
Cette semaine c'est pas une explication de mentalisme mais de magie mental hein
C'est quasiment la même chose, ils sont assez voisins l'un et l'autre
Pour ça je vais prendre un jeu de cartes ESP.
Est-ce que vous vous souvenez bien de ce qu'est un symbole ESP ?
Ce sont les cartes de Zener vous savez ? Avec la croix, le cercle, les vagues, l'étoile et le carré
On en a parlé sur une autre vidéo d'un dimanche.
Et bien ce coup-ci ses cartes là vont nous permettre de maîtriser le hasard, voilà.
J'ai pensé à ça hier, je pense que ça peut vous intéresser.
Pour faire cet effet à vos amis, vous avez soit besoin d'acheter un jeux de cartes ESP, vous tapez ça sur internet
"jeux de cartes ESP" vous trouvez
Je ne vous en recommande pas un en particulier
Mais vous pouvez faire la même chose vous même en prenant des papiers
soit que vous découpez soit des petites... comme des cartes de visites aussi, au dos de cartes de visites, voilà.
Peu importe le format, vous êtes pas obligés d'en avoir 52 en fait.
Vous pouvez en avoir juste une trentaine ou une quarantaine
Y'a pas besoin d'avoir un nombre précis pour faire ça.
Comme ça je suis certain que vous pourrez le faire vous aussi.
Comme d'habitude je vous fais d'abord la démonstration pour que vous puissiez bien vivre l'effet
et ensuite je vous explique, ce sera rapide
Imaginons que j'ai quelqu'un près de moi
- Salut !
- Salut Fabien !
Est-ce que tu veux bien mélanger ce jeu là pour moi ?
Ce sont des cartes ESP, euh...
J'ai pas trop le temps de t'expliquer ce que c'est mais si tu regardes les vidéos de...
et bah de moi en fait, ah ah je me perd dans mes "je" !
- Mais j'ai déjà regardé la vidéo Fabien ! Tu imagines  bien que je suis abonné !
Alors je te mélange tes cartes, il n'y a pas de problèmes.
C'est vrai, tu mélanges très très bien, merci à toi.
Je vais devenir schizophrène moi...
Alors je vais sortir 5 cartes du jeu.
Pas n'importe lesquelles évidemment.
Je vais sortir une étoile, euh...un rond, des vagues, une croix et un carré.
Je vais les mettre ici : étoile, carré, croix, cercle et vagues.
Bon, comme je ne peux plus m'asseoir là je vais vous expliquer le but du jeu.
Maintenant, c'est d'expliquer a votre spectateur, qu'il va devoir mettre les cartes comme ceci en face
mais un peu dans l'ordre qu'il veut.
Il peut faire un peu n'importe quoi en fait jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait plus de cartes.
Donc imaginons qu'il fasse ça...Là il en met une dizaine... ici... là il les met une par une... il revient là...il revient là... il revient là... là... là et ici, c'est magnifique !
Plaçons ensuite les cartes face en l'air sur les petits tas qui ont été fait
Et pour chaque tas, on va couper, et remettre la coupe sur le dessus.
Et enfin de réunir toutes les cartes en un seul paquet.
C'est-à-dire on repose les cartes dans l'ordre qu'on veut pour avoir au final un seul gros paquet.
Comme ça !
Ce test de perception extra-sensoriel nous permet de voir si notre spectateur
sur une échelle de 1 à 5 a une perception particulière des choses.
Et pour vérifier ça, pour regarder ça, on va faire défiler le jeu
et à chaque fois qu'on a une carte en l'air, on va la sortir avec la carte en bas qui est juste au-dessus.
Idem, là je vais prendre la carte qui est face en l'air avec la carte qui est juste sur le dessus.
Pareil pour la troisième.
Pareil pour la quatrième.
Et enfin pareil pour la cinquième !
Ce jeu était évidemment composé de tous les symboles des cartes ESP mélangés les uns aux autres.
Et pourtant, grâce à la perception étrange et fascinante de votre spectateur.
Si on retourne la carte des vagues, sur le dessus il y avait la carte des vagues
si on retourne la carte étoile, sur le dessus il y avait la carte étoile
sur la carte croix il y avait la carte croix, sur la carte carré il y avait la carte carré évidemment !
Et sur la carte rond, nous avions également la carte rond!
C'est pas mystérieux ça ?
Malgré toutes les coupes et les mélanges qui ont été fait.
Le spectateur a réussi à réunir les 5 cartes avec sa distribution à lui.
Du moins c'est ce qu'il croit
parce que vous y êtes un petit peu pour quelque chose.
Nous passons maintenant à la partie explications.
Étape n°1 : Vous donnez le jeu, réellement, à mélanger à un spectateur.
Et ensuite, c'est la seule chose importante que vous ayez, salut ! , c'est la seule chose importante que vous ayez à faire pour la suite
donc retenez bien ça.
Vous allez prendre le jeu face à vous, le spectateur ne doit pas forcément voir ce que vous faites
et vous allez les 5 symboles ESP différents ici devant vous, sur votre table.
Mais vous devez secrètement faire en sorte également que les 5 premières cartes soient les 5 symboles ESP différents.
Ce qu'est pas le cas par pour moi mais je vais vous faire voir comment on règle ce léger problème.
Vous passez la première carte : c'est le carré, vous la gardez en mains. Là, c'est les vagues, je la garde en mains
le cercle je le garde en main, la croix je garde en main
le carré je l'ai déjà donc au lieu de le garder en mains, je vais le poser sur la table.
Ensuite, l'étoile je ne l'avais pas donc je la garde ici.
Et maintenant, je vais juste aller chercher à mettre les 5 symboles différents sur la table.
Donc j'ai 5 symboles différents sur la table et les 5 premières cartes que j'ai dans les mains sont aussi 5 symboles.
Je retiens leur ordre, je retiens l'ordre.
Moi, pour retenir l'ordre, j'ai une technique très très simple.
Si vous vous souvenez de la vidéo où je vous apprenais à vous servir de ça pour deviner un dessin
et bah j'utilise mon comptage.
C'est à dire que là je met du 4, comme c'est le carré 4
3 parce qu'il y a 3 vagues
1 parce qu'il y a juste 1 seul trait
2 parce qu'il y a 2 traits et 5 parce qu'il y a 5 traits.
Donc je retiens 43, je retiens 14 et je retiens 5 : 43, 14, 5.
De toutes manières, je ne le retiens que quelques secondes vous allez voir pourquoi.
Parce que là, je vais tout remettre dans le même ordre en fait
Ici, je prend mon 43, 14 et 5.
Récapitulatif parce qu'après c'est très simple.
J'ai mis sur la table 5 cartes, pas dans n'importe quel symbole
dans le même symbole que les 5 premières cartes de mon paquet
mes 5 cartes différentes, donc si je vérifie, j'ai bien
le carré, les vagues, le cercle, la croix et l'étoile
Maintenant, vous allez expliquer à votre spectateur ce qu'il doit faire
donc vous prenez les cartes unes par une en disant :
Tu vas mettre les cartes à chaque fois devant les symboles que j'ai mis face en l'air
en faisant tout ce que tu veux, dans l'ordre que tu veux, tu peux en mettre plusieurs d'un coup
une ici, deux là, une là...c'est tout comme tu veux.
Le fait de lui montrer ce qu'il a à faire ça a 2 sens :
le sens réel qui est de lui expliquer
et le sens caché qui est le fait d'avoir mis devant chaque carte
la première carte hein que vous avez posée devant chaque carte, c'est la carte correspondante
la carte identique.
Et ça, c'est la clé de cet effet.
Ensuite, vous lui demandez de mettre sur chaque paquet correspondant la carte qui est face en l'air juste en face
et à chaque fois de faire une coupe, et de compléter cette coupe.
C'est-a-dire que là par exemple, je fais une coupe,
et je complète la coupe comme ceci.
Et il fait ça pour les 5 paquets.
Dernière étape, vous lui demandez de réunir tous les paquets dans l'ordre qu'il veut.
En fait, ça a pas d'importance.
Il récupère les 5 paquets pour n'en avoir plus qu'un seul.
Et c'est terminé !
C'est que vous avez ramené sur les cartes qui étaient face en l'air la carte identique que vous avez posée juste avant.
Ce qui fait que si vous étalez le jeu
soit sur une table ou soit dans vos mains
et que vous sortez les cartes face en l'air avec la première carte qui est sur la face en l'air
comme ceci.
Vous allez automatiquement aboutir à un résultat de 5/5 dans la réussite de votre spectateur.
A savoir, il auras mis sur le carré, le carré.
Sur la croix, la croix.
Sur les vagues, les vagues.
Sur l'étoile, l'étoile et enfin sur le cercle, quelle surprise ! Un cercle.
Félicitez bien votre spectateur pour ce petit miracle, parce que c'est lui qui a travaillé
vous n'avez rien a en retirer, c'est lui qu'il faut applaudir.
J'espère que cette explication vous auras plu, que vous allez essayer de le faire sur d'autres personnes.
N'hésitez pas a acheter un jeu ou a faire vous même des cartes sur des bouts de papier.
Vous prenez une feuille A4, vous la découpez en 16, pareil avec une deuxième.
Ça vous fait un jeu de 32 cartes, c'est très bien hein.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit pouce en l'air et surtout à vous abonner !
Abonnez-vous à la chaîne je compte sur vous pour le faire.
Partagez cette vidéo autant que vous le voulez.
Si vous essayez de faire cet effet sur quelqu'un, racontez-moi dans les commentaires comment ça s'est passé.
Est-ce que la personne a aimé, est-ce que vous vous êtes fait avoir.
Est-ce que vous avez raté ? Réussis ?
J'adore lire tout ça !
J'adore lire vos retours d'expériences.
Passez un excellent dimanche et rendez-vous demain à 17h sur cette chaîne Youtube !
Ciao !